to have mark zandry here
so um mark's uh spoken at the colloquium
before so i'm sure many of you know
about him already but um
he's
mark
started his uh his career as uh working
in cryptography and classical
cryptography but
but he's um he's been over the years
he's worked a lot on on the quantum on
the
foundations the quantum foundations of
cryptography or the foundation of
cryptography in a quantum world and
at this point i think we can we can
safely say he's
he's as much of um
you know of uh research and quantum
information science as anybody else and
and um
so today he'll talk about
a very exciting new paper that he's uh
he just posted
on
verifiable um
advantage
without
you know
in the absence of structure so
mark really looking forward to this talk
all right thank you for the introduction
let me start the share
all right
right so today i'll be talking about a
very recent work with takashi yamakawa
on verifying quantum advantage without
structure
so this talk is time for about 45
minutes so there should hopefully be
plenty of room for questions um so i'll
try to pause the route and answer
questions as they come up
um also i know this is a quantum
colloquium but in case anyone is
watching maybe less familiar with
quantum computation i'll try to keep the
talk pretty accessible
so before diving into the results let me
spend some time to clarify what we mean
by all these terms and to give a short
survey of my work and also to motivate
the setting for our results
so we start with the defining question
of the field of quantum computing which
is do quantum computers give
speed ups over
classical computers also known as
advantage
for this talk we are not interested in
grover type speed ups that achieve
polynomial advantage even though such
speed ups are of course super important
in practice
but where super polynomial speedups
shine is that they allow quantum
computers to completely crush the
classical competition by solving a
problem quickly that classical computers
won't be able to solve until well after
the universe ends this will be our goal
now if we have a quantum computer we
would ideally like to know that it is
actually solving the problem of disposal
we would actually like to verify that it
is you know doing something quantum
and verification is also fundamental to
quantum computing as as ultimately we
want
quantum computers to have real-world
impact
observing such real-world impact really
is a form of verification if quantum
computers are better at simulating
chemical reactions we'll see this
through say the utility of drugs
that we can design as a result
if quantum computers can break
cryptography we'll see this through
security compromises if quantum
computers
are better at machine learning we'll see
this through
improved artificial intelligence
in many cases such as with cryptography
uh the verification that we get is
entirely a classical algorithm
in general though if we assume the
universe is at least a quantum turing
machine
if the universe can verify
as evidence through the real world
impact this at least means there's a
quantum algorithm for verification
um a particularly important question is
whether there is quantum advantage in
the complexity class np
np is the most important class of heart
problems in computer science and it's
the class of problems whose solutions
can be verified efficiently without
interaction on a classical computer
these capture many but of course not all
of the most important problems people
care about
um okay so so now we're going to define
the last term which is structure
structure has long played a central role
in proposals for quantum advantage in
the sense that structure seems to be
what separates
problems that have super polynomial
advantage such as factoring from those
that don't like np complete problems
now structure isn't well defined and
there's really many reasonable ways to
talk about structure for quantum
advantage
in this talk i'll take a complexity
theoretic view structure motivated as
follows um any setting that requires
fast
any setting for quantum advantage
requires certainly a fast quantum
algorithm but it also requires a lower
bound on the running time of any
classical algorithm
and the sad truth is with the current
state of complexity theory we can't hope
to prove uh such good lower bounds for
classical algorithms
so we need some
extra piece of help
and there are really two main approaches
the the first is an oracle separation
where we specify some oracle some
function relative to which we can obtain
a quantum advantage
um and this function can only be
accessed through oracle access
classical algorithms can of course only
make classical queries to this oracle so
they send a classical acts and get f x
in response
but quantum algorithms can now make
quantum queries on superpositions of
inputs
introducing oracles helps essentially
because we can actually prove lower
bounds on the number of queries
and a lower bounded number of queries in
particular implies a lower bound on the
runtime
so the hope is to find an oracle where
the so-called query complexity of some
problem gives a super polynomial gap
between classical and quantum
now in order for
our separation to be the most meaningful
we would naturally like to have the
simplest or least structured oracle
possible
what is the minimal structure
here well it seems clear it seems that a
uniform random oracle is the minimal
structured oracle because essentially by
definition it can't have any special
features
uh so in oracle separations are where
we'll take structure
or we'll take the lack of structure to
mean a random oracle
the other approach is to simply
conjecture some classical hardness by
making a computational assumption
now we would naturally like the minimal
possible assumption and one that is most
widely believed so as to get results
that are as close as possible to
unconditional and therefore most likely
to be true
there are a wide variety of possible
assumptions that can be made
and while these assumptions are
generally incomparable
we can do some reasonable partial
ordering on the far left we have
unconditional
results the holy grail which as we just
said are out of reach
another
common assumption is that p is not equal
to np
if we want quantum advantage for an np
problem we certainly must assume at
least that p is not equal to np
uh but we may have to assume more so
we're at least stuck to the right of p
not equal to np
moving further to the right we
eventually get to the assumed existence
of symmetric key cryptography this is
basically the minimal requirement to do
secure communication and most classical
assumptions
as we move further still we eventually
get to classical public key cryptography
the backbone of the modern internet and
as we keep moving right we start seeing
famous number of theoretical problems
such as the hardness factoring discrete
logarithms pairings on elliptic curves
learning with errors or do we
there also may be less famous examples
like the hardness of isogenes between
elliptic curves you may disagree with me
on the exact ordering between these
problems but the hardness of all of
these problems implies in particular
public encryption so certainly they they
fall to the right of public key crypto
um so in the second option for
conditional separations
um the concept of structures is is
definitely more squishy than the oracle
case and as a rough definition what
we're going to take for structure is to
mean the assumed classical hardness of
the problem
is not known to imply classical public
encryption
the justification for this is exactly
that all the assumptions that imply
public key encryption are algebraic
assumptions with significant algebraic
structure
uh in contrast say symmetric for
symmetric key crypto um we can build
symmetric key cryptography from
functions whose sole java that it is to
scramble their input essentially
functions whose job is to mimic random
oracles so we have a strong correlation
between algebraic structure and the
ability to build public encryption
and our two notions of structure for the
oracle and conditional setting are very
closely linked in one direction given
any result relative to a random oracle
um
we can heuristically instantiate it
using a concrete cryptographic hash
function such as sha-256
giving a plausible conditional
construction from just symmetric key
tools
there's a long history of cryptography
of modeling cryptographic hash functions
as random oracles to understand their
security properties so this heuristic is
very well
studied there are counter examples to to
this kind of heuristic but they're
always contrived and tend to have a
little impact on real world applications
um
another supporting evidence for our
notion of structure is
that um pagliato and rudic showed that
random oracles alone cannot be used to
construct public encryption
uh meanwhile random oracles can be used
to construct most of symmetric key
cryptography
so really there are two notions of
structure are quite compatible with each
other
um i'll just briefly mention an aside
that's not relevant for this talk but um
it's just a fascinating and open
question is that it is not known if
random oracles imply public key
encryption where encryption and
decryption may be quantum but
communication is still classical
i mean this is why i keep saying that
random oracles cannot give classical
public encryption we don't know if the
analogous result holds or not for
quantum
and i think this is a extremely
interesting open question
um
maybe i can pause here for
to see if there are any questions
um so mark can you repeat what you said
the at the end
what is not known from
uh from random oracle um
we we don't know if
a if using quantum computation locally
but classical communication we don't
know if you can build public encryption
from random oracles got it okay there
there's some there's some work on this
that is that is hinted that the answer
is that you can't
uh but we haven't been able to
actually lift the empogliatsu rudich
result to the quantum setting
are there any other questions
okay
move on
um so we can summarize the prior work in
the following picture uh so we can
categorize the prior justifications of
quantum advantage
according to whether they are verifiable
on whether or not they are structureless
um the earliest justifications uh due to
bernstein and vasarani and later simon
gave oracle separating bqp from bpp
these problems could be verified however
the oracles were highly structured both
utilizing some form of periodicity
basically such periods can be observed
quantumly but remain hidden classically
not long afterward we get uh schwarz
famous algorithm for solving factoring
and discrete logarithms which are
presumably hard for classical computers
these two are verifiable and don't
involve oracles
but uh they do imply public key
encryption
and this is you know the main
uh danger of short's algorithm is is the
fact that they can break much of the
public key cryptography we use today
um shore's algorithm was followed by
hogan's algorithm for solving pell's
equations and as well as bavayal's
algorithm for matrix group membership
um and what's interesting is that all
these examples of um
non-relativized verifiable advantage
uh are for problems whose classical
hardness can be used to build public key
encryption
at a technical level these works all
all operate by giving
highly non-trivial reductions from the
stated problems to finding the period of
some periodic function
in other words they can be seen as
real-world instantiations of periodic
oracles
um on the other side we have a problem
called fourier sampling or fourier
fishing proposed by anderson
this is a problem defined relative to a
random oracle and therefore
structureless
which is easy for quantum computers but
unconditionally hard for classical
computers
and then below that we have standard
model results by bremner and others
which basically show that simulating
quantum simulating output distribution
of a quantum circuit is classically hard
i mean these results uh follow under
plausible general complexity theoretic
conjectures and are also there for
structuralists
right and neither neither of these
problems on the right
uh can imply are known to imply public
key encryption
however in both cases verification is
intractable um and actually uh
verification costs essentially as much
as classically solving the problem
uh and moreover verification
plausibly even remains hard even if you
have a quantum computer to do the
verification
uh one more result i'll briefly mention
is a recent
somewhat more recent work of process uh
which i put on the edge of the
verifiable bubble since they give an
interactive protocol as opposed to
non-interactive problem like an mp
statement
so it's a you know a little bit weaker
in terms of the verifiability what was
quite fascinating about this one though
uh is that
uh
lwe
the underlying assumption of this
protocol appears to remain hard for
quantum computers and so it's it's quite
surprising that you can get quantum
advantage out of a problem that is
actually
not believed to be quantumly easy
there are of course tons of other
results in the literature
and and i won't really mention them but
to the best of my knowledge the results
here are representative of the current
state of the affairs
and uh where our work
uh shows up is in the intersection of
these two bubbles
uh which was previously empty
mark can i ask a question yeah could you
say this yes you didn't understand that
statement saying that it's surprising
that you can get an advantage
for a problem that's considered to be
hard for quantum advantage is that it's
hard
so
right what i mean is that so so what is
the quantum advantage uh at least for
the context of this talk quantum
advantage means something that's
classically easy but quantum hard
and with lwe we believe it's
quantum
uh it's classically hard and also
quantum hard
so you're saying you're you're getting
this verifiability of quantum hardness
from a problem that itself is called
apart okay so that that is the conundrum
there okay yeah
all right can i also ask the question
here so yes i i'm
you want structureless i'm trying to
understand uh if i understand your
motivation completely so i understand if
your motivation is look these
assumptions i don't know if they're if i
believe them of course i believe kind of
one-way function or you know symmetric
encryption is a weaker assumption and i
want to kind of get quantum advantage uh
from the weakest possible assumption is
that your motivating goal or is there
something else that
yeah i mean as we'll see when we get to
our results are we we don't get a result
that's like you know one-way functions
or or some particular
um assumption that people studied before
but the the point is to
um
to understand
the extent to which structure is is
needed for quantum advantage uh and and
yeah structure is not really well
defined um the view of this talk is
where we're taking structure to roughly
correlate with the strength of the
assumption um in terms of like implied
cryptography got it so this is kind of a
fundamental question you're interested
in it's not just about kind of okay got
it things right
okay um
good so so before moving on to actually
stating what our results are i i do want
to just give a couple more remarks
so so first we observe that all
non-relativizing
np problems demonstrating quantum
advantage
rely essentially on period finding we
just don't have a lot of techniques
compatible with np for giving a quantum
advantage
um and for example the lwe proof of
quantumness that i mentioned on the last
slide it doesn't give you an mp problem
so it doesn't rely on period finding but
it also doesn't give you an np problem
because it's interactive
uh second we observe that all
structuralist sources of advantage are
basically sampling problems where the
task is to sample from a distribution as
opposed as opposed to outputting a
particular output or or a member of a
particular set
um the distribution may in fact have
non-zero-way tunnel inputs which means
that given a single sample you actually
can't determine if the algorithm is
sampling from the correct distribution
you can of course turn such problems
into more traditional computational
problems by looking at lists of many
samples
but the the point is you're starting
from a problem where verification is is
not really a
an inherent feature
and usually when you try to turn it into
a
a problem of a search problem uh you
generally get something that's
computationally intractable
um
finally
i want to mention something uh called
the aronson and venus conjecture so
anton and venus investigated the
relationship between structure and
quantum speedups for a couple possible
notions of structure
uh
some of which act differed from the kind
of structure we're talking about today
uh but importantly for us they write
down a conjecture summarize informally
uh in the picture here
which roughly says that
if you have any quantum algorithm a
which i've denoted in ket notation
that makes q queries to a random oracle
and outputs a single bit
that there is a classical
simulator
that makes only polynomially more
queries to the random oracle and can
approximately simulate the distribution
of outputs
so this conjecture actually predates the
work of erinson and venus going back at
least to 2000
now there's there's no reason a priority
for believing this conjecture
but it has been a central conjecture in
quantum query complexity for some time
and has remained unrefuted
moreover anton and venus show that this
conjecture actually follows from a
different conjecture
which on the face of it has nothing to
do with quantum computing it's some
conjecture about the behavior of bounded
low-degree polynomials
this this other conjecture
it in turn is closely related to other
results that have been proven
um and so while the the while everything
still remains a conjecture here there
there is some
good evidence
that the conjecture may be true
uh so what's what's the implication of
this conjecture
well if we think of a quantum algorithm
as solving some decision problem
efficiently
what the a conjecture
yields is a classical algorithm for the
same problem that is query efficient
now uh and what this says roughly is
that we can't hope to separate bqp from
bpp
just by looking at query complexity
uh but introducing oracle's was kind of
the whole point of
of uh or
separating uh
complexity class that's kind of the
whole point of introducing these oracles
and working in a query model
um now you know it could certainly be
that as the classical simulator is
computationally inefficient
um and and you would expect this to be
necessary if say you know a ignored its
random oracle unfactored integers or
something like that
but demonstrating the computational
inefficiency of s is essentially a
non-relativized problem defeating the
whole point of using the oracle
so the the takeaway is that it to
whatever extent you believe the aronson
and venus conjecture
uh random oracles don't seem to help in
giving separation for decision problems
in np
okay um and so with that let's let's get
to the results mark sorry uh yeah what
do you mean by approximately zero so
this is a decision problem right and you
you you you're saying the output should
the output of s should uh
be the correct answer with a high
probability that's that's what you mean
yeah let's so let's say on a particular
input a outputs one with probability
two-thirds then s should output one with
probability
you know uh something a little less less
than two-thirds potentially but close to
two-thirds okay right and the conjecture
is a little more precise than this um it
also includes it's actually polyq and
one over epsilon where epsilon is the
the error that you're willing to
tolerate let's see i see um so so you
so your point uh your point here is that
um
so either i have to
either this conjecture is bad news
or i need to assume something about a
problem that a computationally unbounded
s can solve but a computationally
bounded s cannot which sort of takes us
what is that problem you know like that
takes us back to uh it seems it seems to
defeat the point of looking at random or
looking at a query model
okay i see thanks
unless the conjecture is false
unless the conjecture is false yes and
you know it could turn out that the
conjecture is false
um
just one question i mean you you
your left top bullet all existing
sources of advantage and rely on period
finding i was wondering if you thought
about rather than talking about np about
things that are refutable
you know there's this sort of definition
of refutability in crypto as a
reasonable assumptions
um
you know something refutability
refutability in one sense like co-np
no in the sense that if it's false
you'll be able to kind of demonstrate
the fact that it's false but not
necessarily
um
written down proof
uh
you know like factoring is irrefutable
the fact that being hard is refutable
and other
it
seems to me that that's what you're
getting at
uh
when you're talking about np
right i mean i i i guess i think about
it in the language of of like a protocol
for verifying advantage where np
corresponds more or less to a
non-interactive protocol
and you could consider interactive
protocols and and this is what the the
work based on lwe does for example
uh so yeah it is certainly reasonable to
um
consider
uh a quantum advantage
that doesn't correspond to an np problem
um
but also you know i think it's pretty
interesting to consider whether there is
quantum advantage for mp problems
okay
so so mark if i may one more question so
the the top left thing right i mean you
could take the lwe uh based interactive
protocol right bcmvp uh and try to
premiere it into a two message protocol
but that you're saying that doesn't give
you np problems because it's human which
you can't you can't fiat shamira because
it's not public coin
not all the way through but some of it
is public coin all except the first
message is public right
oh i see it's not publicly verifiable
you're saying okay yeah exactly um and
on the right on the top right uh could
you take the sort of the structure-less
sort of sampling problem and have the
prover actually run an interactive proof
convincing the verified that it's
sampled correctly
the problem isn't b space probably so
you could run ip but you're saying you
need the prover to be
efficient in bqp as well
right yeah yeah so certainly there are
ways to take the
sampling problems and try to turn them
into
um you know verifiable problems but
um it yeah it seems like it it always
ends up resulting in um you know
something inefficient
yeah
yeah
okay
so if there's no other questions i will
go on to what our results are
um
so so here's our results um
so we give the following results
relative to a random oracle with
probability one
so first we we show that there are
actually np search problems solvable by
bqp machines but not bpp machines and
note the restriction to search as
opposed to decision npe problems um
importantly our our instances are
actually always trivially yes instances
so the decision problem is easy
[Music]
and this is somewhat inherent unless we
want to make progress on the the aaa
conjecture
um
that you know if we're going to have an
unconditional result
we we we can't be um giving the
separation for decision problems
um and i i don't know i found this a
little surprising um just because you
know we all we often
don't pay attention to the distinction
between search and decision and here
here was actually very important
um so next we we study the implications
to cryptography and we show that there
are a number of crypto objects
that are classically hard but quantumly
easy again relative to a random oracle
these include one-way functions
collision-resistant hashing and digital
signatures
if we additionally assume public key
encryption that is
at least classically secure we obtain a
separation for public encryption as well
that is we can construct
public encryption that is classically
hard but quantumly easy whether or not
the original
scheme was quantumly easy
and note that for for the public
encryption separation assuming pke is is
essentially
required uh since we know that random
oracles alone cannot give public
encryption
um the separations uh that we have
trivially also yield uh this thing
called a proof of quantumness which is a
protocol between a quantum prover
a protocol between a quantum improver
and a classical verifier
uh
where
the
quantum improver actually proves to the
classical verifier that it is quantum
our protocols have as few rounds as
possible here the minimal rounds depends
on whether we consider uniform or
non-uniform adversaries for uniform
adversaries our proofs are
non-interactive
uh for for the next results
you know as we said we we don't make any
progress on refuting or confirming the a
conjecture so we still find it quite
plausible that the aaa conjecture holds
and under this conjecture we show that
we can lift our proof of quantumness to
obtain certifiable randomness
again in minimal rounds so what is a
certifiable randomness protocol it's a
protocol that allows a quantum server to
generate uniform randomness for a
classical client
and even if the server deviates from the
protocol you still want to guarantee
that the string produced by the
classical client is random
um and then a final thing it's not
really a result but just a
you know remark is that we can get
non-relativized candidate versions of
all of the above results
uh by replacing the random oracle with a
concrete cryptographic hash function
such as shot 56
as noted already there's a huge body of
literature which models uh standard
cryptographic hash functions as a random
oracle anyway for the security analysis
uh and so we can make uh the heuristic
assumption that security in the random
oracle model um apply security when
instantiated
with sha-256
mark can i google equipment
every time when you say classically
hired by quantum easy you mean
classically secure but quantum broken
right
yes
any other questions before i
dive into the construction
um just like a question
more of a guess is the difference here
between search and decision that it
would decision you can amplify your
probability of correctness and with
search you don't
not not really um basically
you can think of
basically what happens is we construct
something you can view as a one-way
function that is
very compressing and so all possible
elements in the code domain are actually
images of the function
and so in some sense the the analogous
np problem which is you know given a
given uh element in the codomain does it
have a pre-image that that np problem is
trivially always
yes
uh because every element
has a pre-image um but it still remains
the the function still remains one way
at least classically
um and so that's why it's you know it's
a search problem that's hard rather than
a decision problem that's hard i see and
in that case you do not have a reduction
from
like the previous slideshows
from a query
uh on a quantum to query classes
right right yeah so so um
this erinson and venus conjecture uh you
know it sort of really fundamental uh to
the conjecture that the the output of
the adverse series is zero one
um and the the reason is you know it's
maybe not as clear from from the
from the picture i drew here but it has
to do with the fact that this you know
this paul eq actually also depends on
the error you're willing to tolerate
and um if if you have exponentially many
outputs for your function
um
you know basically if you want
if you want s to actually simulate a
um you need your error to be very very
tiny in order for it to be a meaningful
simulation that's why i thought that it
had to do with amplification so if it
was zero one you could kind of amplify
if you have exponentially many of them
what's the chance you're ever going to
see it again yeah right
so it works here so you're saying the
reason this works is that you can
amplify but the reason your thing works
is entirely different yeah sure
you know the publicly verifiable proof
of quantumness right i mean is it in the
is it using oracles or not using oracles
so so except for the random oracle or
the conjectured version with shot256
there's no oracles but there is a random
article really right i mean yes yes all
right
yeah everything in the in this light
blue box is relative to a random oracle
and it because it's one it's known to
act it's not interactive it's just one
message yeah
it it it depends on whether you're
talking about uniform or non-uniform
adversaries there's a subtlety with
non-uniform adversaries but for uniform
it's it's not interactive
okay uh so so let's describe our
construction
uh so here's our hard problem
we start from a high dimensional large
alphabet linear code that i'll call c
i'm going to use the terminology code
since coding theory will be important in
a few slides but you can just think of
this as a as a
you can think of a linear code as just a
linear subspace mod q for some large
integer q
so here's a picture of some code
um and not you know obviously i can only
draw two dimensions easily but
we'll think of our code as being very
high dimensional you know some hundreds
of dimensions
so to start we'll start with something
that's actually easy but we'll start
with the problem of simply finding a
code word in this code
since our since our code is linear
finding a code word just involves
solving linear algebra you know
regardless of the dimension this is easy
so what we're going to do is we're going
to make things slightly harder for the
adversary
um what we're going to do is we're going
to choose a random subset of the x
coordinates just every every possible x
coordinate will
will be in our set with probability of
half
and now we will say that valid solutions
are code words
that must have an x coordinate belonging
to the set of valid x coordinates that
we chose
right so
now okay i guess our alphabet will be
exponentially large so we cannot simply
provide
the set of x coordinates in the clear
and this is this is where the random
oracle comes in we'll interpret the
random oracle as a set of x coordinates
that is for each possible x coordinate
the random oracle will contain one bit
valid x coordinates are those whose
random oracle bit is say zero
we can therefore test if an x coordinate
is valid by making a single query to the
oracle
so we've made our problem slightly
harder
by eliminating roughly half of the code
words from contention
of course the problem is still not all
that hard you can sample a random code
word using linear algebra
and then just throw away throw it away
and start over again if the x coordinate
happens to be invalid
in expectation you only have to generate
two code words before you find a you
find one with a valid x coordinate
so we've really only doubled the
difficulty you can still solve this
easily in polynomial time
uh so what do we do well we have other
coordinates at our disposal so now we do
the same thing for the y coordinate we
choose another random set
of
coordinates that we are going to call
valid for the y coordinate
we'll want our valid y coordinates to be
chosen independently from our valid x
coordinates
um and but this is easily handled uh
just by using a slightly larger random
orbital where we split the random oracle
in half using one half to decide
for valid x coordinates and the other
half to decide valid y coordinates
so now um we've we've made the problem
of finding
a solution slightly harder still
as a random code word will
simultaneously have a valid x and a
valid y coordinate with probability
a fourth um so this means we've you know
we've multiplied the difficulty by a
fourth in expectation the the trivial
algorithm of sample around code word and
then test if it's coordinates are valid
you'll have to repeat about four times
for you before you get
a valid solution but we still have an
easy problem we've only multiplied the
difficulty by four
uh but this is why we chose a high
dimensional code so we just repeat this
for all possible coordinates
um for every single coordinate we'll
we'll choose a random subset
of the values for that coordinate that
we'll say are valid and a solution to
our problem will be a code word
who whose each uh position is considered
valid
and the hope is that the difficulty
scales exponentially with the dimension
when we consider just x coordinates we
multiply by two y coordinates by four
if we have a hundred coordinates you
know the hope would be that we multiply
the difficulty by two to the hundred
so mark uh
yeah the rate of the code is large
enough that even after you place these
constraints there is uh there is a sort
of some code word that satisfies
yes
okay
yeah yeah and you know it'll it i i
don't i won't really go into like the
exact parameters of the code in this
talk but you could think of the code as
having rate
somewhere around a half
um there's like there's a lot of
flexibility actually in the rate of the
code
um
but yes it's it's a high rate code
uh so there will certainly be
a lot of solutions
but
but hopefully we've made hopefully this
process has made the
made it hard to find solutions and and
certainly the the trivial algorithm
doesn't
won't work
okay
um so that that's the problem we define
um and
now the lingering questions are
why is it classically hard we've
explained why the trivial algorithm
doesn't work but maybe there's a more
clever approach
the second question is why on earth
should this be quantumly easy
and then finally both of these questions
are potentially dependent on the choice
of code so we need to understand what
code to use
all right so let's start with classical
hardness
um we first note that our construction
is a case of what i'll call a domain
constraint linear equation where the
goal is to find a solution to a linear
system that also satisfies additional
nonlinear constraints these have some
history in cryptography for example itai
consider random linear codes combined
with a constraint on the l2 norm
the result is what's known as the short
integer solution problem one of the
foundations of lattice
cryptography a more recent example
considered enough a few works is to take
a random binary linear code and
constrain to low hamming weight
both these sets of problems appear to be
computationally intractable and just in
general it seems that once you mix
um highly non-linear constraints with
linear equations there's uh you know
there's a chance to actually get some
good hardness
now it turns out in our case because we
have this oracle around we actually can
um prove unconditionally the classical
hardness as long as we make an
appropriate choice of code of our code
um so so so first we have to give some
notation and definitions
given a a word c
and a product of sets s1 up to sn
we can define the distance between c and
the product
as the fraction of symbols of c
that are not in the corresponding set in
the product
so some notion of distance between
words and products of sets
and then we'll say that a code c is list
recoverable
uh
here's a you know more precise thing but
i'll just say it in words um if for any
product of small sets s1 up to sn
there are a relatively small number of
code words with small distance from
the product set
um
and note here that we don't care about
usually we care about in in coding
theory usually care about the efficiency
of of of doing you're decoding here we
actually don't care about the efficiency
we we just really care about the fact
that the set of code words of small
distance is small
and note that list recoverability is a
generalization of list decoding where in
list decoding these sis are just
singletons
um unless decoding in in turn is a
generalization of standard error
correction where
the
the size of this set here is is supposed
to be one
by generalizing to list decoding and
then to list recoverability we handle
large sets and we also allow for more
flexibility in the parameters of our
code by not insisting that the list size
is one
so error correction is of course very
well studied
and list recoverability in particular
has been studied in a few works
i mean there are no there are a couple
positive results here um the first
example is by guru swami and rudra
who showed that a code called the folded
read solomon code is is list recoverable
this is basically just re solomon except
where you can where you take reed
solomon you kind of package
the symbols uh the package the symbols
of resulman to groups and then each
group becomes uh a symbol of your new
code
um so it's basically just read solomon
and then more recently
rudra and wuters showed that a random
linear code is also list recoverable
so what we show is that if c is
recoverable
then our problem is actually classically
intractable
and we and you know we actually
concretely give a success probability
upper bound for any polynomial time
adversary in terms of the parameters of
the code
the intuition here is basically that
list recoverability
more or less corresponds to
the trivial attack and or let's recover
list recoverability more or less shows
that the trivial attack
is the only attack um up to some sub
exponential uh loss um
to generate code words
um
it turns out you can do a bit better
than just sampling random code words you
can you can choose
um your symbols carefully such that you
can kind of test the sub-exponential
number of code words all at once
um but it's importantly sub-exponential
um whereas the probability of any
particular code word
actually being
uh valid is exponential
um in the dimension
and and and so we so we get that the
overall probability of finding a valid
codeword is negligible
so this is not under um
uh this is it's not under the assumption
there's an oracle this is just an
absolute theorem
no
it it is relative to an oracle um
yes so yeah i guess my theorem here
should have said classically intractable
relative to arrest where does that come
into your argument
um so so
so basically the argument
so if you look at this expression here
it's a bit inaccurate but um so 2 to the
n to the epsilon prime corresponds
roughly to the number of code words that
you can
um simultaneously
test
and then there's a delta here but let's
ignore that um
uh sorry two to the two to the minus n
is sort of the probability and any
particular code word
um
is a
is valid according to our notion of
valid which is defined relative to the
random oracle
yeah so can i
uh so i want to ask the
questions a little similar to shafi's
which is
okay so first of all she's going back
your definition of list recoverable i
think i may have uh missed it you think
that there exists these parameters delta
epsilon epsilon prime whatever such that
for every set
sets s one up to s n of a certain size
this whole time
okay and now in when you
for your theorem are you gonna take
these x's to be outputs of a random
oracle like the isis the s's are the
queries the ss are the classical queries
um
that the algorithm makes
yeah um and then the the list size
roughly corresponds to the set of code
words that are implicitly being tested
um by those queries
um and then you basically just get a
union bound
it's a little more complicated than that
to handle adaptive queries but more or
less you get a union bound
that you so basically saying the
definition of this recoverability is a
definition with respect to an oracle
the list recoverability is just the
definition from coding theory but these
files but these sets are defined by an
oracle according to you
no uh no no the sets are
the the sets are domain elements oh
they're cool or the random oracle
um
right so list recoverability is just a
concept from from from error correction
there's no oracle or anything it's just
it's just a property of the code
but we show that our problem defined
relative to a random oracle is
intractable
classically if the code that we started
from is list recoverable okay
okay um any other questions so just to
make sure you know the the proof for
algorithms that make non-adaptive
queries is just this right i mean i look
at all my queries to article one two
three they define the sets and then you
have to sort of figure out the
probability that uh
um that these sets sort of hit code
words so they're close to code word
somehow close uh
yeah for non-adapted queries actually
all you care about is whether they hit
code words yeah that's right um you have
to work a little harder for adaptive
queries and that's why you get this like
delta n in the exponent you know you
would sort of naively think it's only
two to the minus n in the exponent
um but when you move to adaptive queries
actually now you start you actually do
start caring about the distance right
right um yeah it makes sense thanks
right now i'll note that like this part
of
of our construction um actually
parallels something that was already
known
list recoverability was actually used
before to construct uh classically hard
hash functions
um
so heightener and all use less
recoverability to construct
hash functions that were highly
parallelizable
um our construction is different from
theirs but the sort of classical
hardness proof follows similar ideas
the the main novelty in our setting is
really the next part though which is uh
getting achieving quantum easiness
uh so let's
let's jump into that
so our starting point is going to be a
technique for what i'll call multiplying
quantum states and i don't know where
the origins of this uh technique are but
at least dates to to regev um
in 2005.
uh so the setup is that we have two
quantum states uh depicted here by plots
where the horizontal axis i'm imagining
is ranging over the
possible outcomes
of the quantum state and the vertical
axis are the amplitudes
of those points
and the goal is to construct
the product of the two states where by
product i mean that the resulting state
the amplitude on any point is the
product of the corresponding amplitudes
of the two input states
now uh right here so here here's what
this would look like in in ket notation
uh now note that in in ket notation i'm
actually ignoring normalization here and
the normalization is is in fact
important
um
but uh for most of this talk i'm i'm
going to kind of push that under the rug
and ignore it and generally be sloppy
about my normalization but just remember
that that it does come up in it and when
you dig into the details and it is
important
i'll say a tad more about this in a few
slides
okay so so so this is the sort of high
level goal
is to do this multiplication of quantum
states
uh so the natural thing to do is to look
in the fourier domain
i'm using the quantum fourier transform
which is one of the you know main tools
in the algorithm toolbox we might as
well you know see what we can do with
them
uh so so if we were to apply or if we
were to look at the fourier domain by
applying the quantum fourier transform
um
what happens uh well if we treat the
plots as a signal what the qft does is
compute the state whose plot is the
fourier transform of the original signal
in our case the the
you know we had a dirac comb and a
gaussian and they
mapped to a different direct a dirac
home in a different gaussian with
different parameters
um now what happens to the product
states uh
well this actually comes from the
convolution theorem so the convolution
theorem says that the fourier transform
of the product is the product of is
sorry the fourier transform of the
product is the convolution of fourier
transforms
um so here here um in the fourier domain
we get the convolution between our um
our comb and our gaussian
and in cat notation this actually has a
nice a nice representation
um
where
uh the contra
where basically we sum over all x y
pairs where x came from the one sigma y
came from the other
um
and each every xy pair
contributes a weight alpha hat x beta
hat x
to the
to the base to the element x plus y
um
so
so what this shows
is that
if we if we want to multiply quantum
states
it suffices to convolve their fourier
transforms
um where the convolution has this form
so this this gives a blueprint for
trying to multiply quantum states so
first step you obtain your two states
separately
um
and here we're just going to assume
every we're just going to you know work
in the fourier domains we're going to
assume we have the two states in the
fourier domain
uh the second step is you do an addition
and superposition because right the the
convolution has this x plus y term
so we we we take our states constructed
separately which have you know an x
comma y
and we just add in superposition to get
x plus y
now we need this operation to be
reversible for it to be a valid quantum
operation so really what we are doing is
applying the map which writes down x
plus y into some newly initialized
registers and leaves the x comma y
behind
um but now if we actually want the
convolution we need to somehow get rid
of the x comma y
uh you might be tempted to say you know
oh you can just discard them but that's
not how it works um these x and y and x
plus y are all all entangled now and if
you try to discard x plus y you're going
to get you're going to get junk
so we need to we need to somehow
eliminate them
and so what we're going to do
is
uh
pretend at least for the moment that we
actually can take x plus y and could
compute
x comma y from x plus y
if we could do such a computation
then we do it we basically apply it in
reverse
to uncompute the x comma y values and
then we're left with the convolution
um so mark can ask something so you want
the decoding to be efficient right uh
for
yes we want we want we want the decoding
to be efficient yes all right
all right um
so so in terms of these steps uh
first one is basically a given we're
just we're just going to be given that
we we have these states um
usually are neither given or easy in our
examples they'll be easy to construct
adding in superposition is easy
[Music]
the last one though not only might it be
computationally intractable but actually
it just might be impossible it might be
that there is not a unique x and y
for a given x plus y
um
and it's not hard to come up with
examples or that's the case so so this
last step is kind of where
where all the difficulty comes in is
this decoding of of x plus y into x and
y
all right just just to emphasize that
decoding is not always possible so we
have our example from before
in this example decoding actually is
possible if uh you know you know for any
point on here
um you actually
you know if you're in the spike here if
your x plus y is in the spike here you
know that x actually came from
from the middle spike over here and then
just your distance from the center of
this hump would tell you the the the y
value from from the signal here
uh there's a you know a slight tiny
chance of error because of the tails of
the gaussian they might overlap
um
but you know let's just pretend that's
not a problem and in fact the air is so
tiny that it effectively doesn't matter
um but now suppose instead of these you
know nice localized uh this nice
localized comb on the left i had you
know something to look more like this
and maybe my gaussian is also a bit
wider
uh now my convolution is i mean it looks
nice but it's kind of a mess to try to
do decoding
um my humps now overlap significantly um
and also
um you know my my distance from the peak
of a hump here might be due to my x
being not at the peak over here or might
be due to my y being not at the peak
over here um and in general for this
example you you wouldn't be able to
decode so um if these were your
fourier domain signals you actually
couldn't do the convolution
um so this in mind i'll briefly explain
regards application to this idea at a
very a very high level
um so so
what does he do so in the primal domain
um
the the first signal is going to just be
the
the indicator for a linear code c so
it's just going to be the uniform
superposition over code words
the second signal is just going to be
some some gaussian weighted signal note
here that we're it's a multi-dimensional
gaussian instead of one dimension so
this really is is somewhat analogous to
the example we just saw
um except generalized to high dimensions
and what is the product well the
um the gaussian forces us to have low
norm um
you know if we were to measure the
the state it would basically the
gaussian here
only has significant weight on things
with low norm
and the
and the the
the indicator for the linear code forces
us to be in the code so the product is
actually a
superposition of short vectors in the
code
and if we measure that we get a short
vector in the code which is solving cis
so what happens in the fourier domain
well
the fourier transform of the indicator
function for linear code is just the
indicator for the dual code
um
meanwhile the fourier transform of the
gaussian is a gaussian there this is not
quite accurate because it's really a
discrete gaussian and it doesn't behave
quite as nicely with fourier transforms
but we can ignore that and just pretend
that the fourier transform is a gaussian
and now what is the decoding problem
it's you take a random code word in the
dual
you add a gaussian weighted
noise to it and you're asked to recover
the original code word and the noise and
this is just uh this is basically just
lwe learning with errors um
and so
uh what regev is able to conclude is
that well if you could solve step three
then you could actually solve cis
so under the assumed quantum hardness of
cis you you lw must be hard and this is
the basis this is the rough basis for
rigorous
reduction um okay so now that we've seen
how to multiply quantum states what
we're going to attempt to do is the same
thing but for our problem except here we
actually do want to solve the decoding
problem
completely
um so inspired by by reagan's algorithm
what we're going to do we're going to
set our one state to be the
superposition over code words
and we're going to set the other state
to be the thing the other constraint
that we're imposing which is the
indicator for valid coordinates
so basically the superposition of valid
vectors of coordinates um but over over
the you know the entire space as opposed
to just code words
and the product of these will be exactly
what we want it'll be a superposition of
solutions to our problem
um so what's left to understand now is
what is the decoding problem in the
fourier domain
and how can we solve this efficiently
uh so just for the linear part just like
regular wait mark sorry yeah sorry can
you go back one slide
yes so the beta yeah the beta x are
defined that's these are going to be
defined by random oracle is that right
yes correct okay
okay yes thanks
um okay
one more thing mark so uh the the beta x
the state can actually be computed
efficiently you're saying because i i do
it for each each coordinate separately
and tensor exactly
right right yeah i didn't mention that
but yes so the
the indicator the superposition over
code words that's just linear algebra
that's easy and for the indicator for
valid coordinates we take advantage of
the fact that
um
basically it's a product state so we can
look at each coordinate separately and
all we have to do is generate the
uniform superposition of all coordinates
test the oracle the oracle rejects we
throw it out and start again
okay
so for the linear part just like in
regev um when we when you look at things
in the fourier domain we just get the
dual code so so that's that's easy
um and for the valid coordinate part
things are different from right give and
we hope they would be if we can if we're
going to solve this um so if we zoom in
on just a single coordinate
the signal will look something like what
i've depicted on the left here it's just
uh it's you know it's just a rant it's
basically just a random
uh you know every every single um
horizontal position is just a random
choice of zero or one for the amplitude
um
now what's interesting is so this is a
mess here but if you look at in the
fourier domain you get something really
nice
the amplitudes actually converge to a
very nice distribution that's um highly
concentrated around zero about half of
the overall weight will will be at zero
so the zero fourier coefficient of you
know of a random function is about a
half
and then all of the other values are
just um more or less uniformly
distributed
now i will say there is a complex phase
that occurs in all these other values
and you sort of need the complex phase
in order to
like because the four transform can't
lose information and needed to encode
all the randomness um in your in your
primal domain and that's where they show
up is in the in the phase in the um
fourier domain
uh but we won't care about the phase all
we actually care about is the amplitudes
um so what does x plus y look like well
x is a dual code word random dual code
word
and y
is just for every coordinate we have
this error distribution where it's um
zero with probability half and random
with probability half
and so what we get is a dual code word
plus random errors in about half the
coordinates
and this is actually a very standard
setting in ear correction
um
note that uh because the fraction of
errors is you know could actually exceed
a half um you know with reasonable
probability um
you this is a setting where you can't
do worst case
decoding
um there are there will be worst case
errors that affect half the positions
that actually result in you know the
inability to uniquely decode
um but what we can take advantage of is
the fact that our errors are actually
random
um and so what we do is it you know we
say if you can list decode
um for about a half let's say a half
plus epsilon fraction of errors if you
can list decode
um well then actually with high
probability your list will have um size
one and that's and that's the
that's the answer for the decoding
problem
um so so this is what this is what we
need in order to get their algorithm to
work is that you can efficiently
list decode a half plus epsilon fraction
of errors um for the dual code
um
okay now okay so now we have we have two
we have two constraints on our code we
need list recoverability in the primal
domain um and the dual code needs to be
um efficiently list decodable
um
now we talked about
random linear codes before random linear
codes won't work here essentially
the list decoding
it's information theoretically possible
but computationally intractable this you
know roughly is analogous to the the lpn
problem
but the good news is that
yes could we take a second just to pause
and sort of uh
talk about the the analog to rugged
right yes sure um what you're saying is
that like morally what the regup step is
letting you do is you get to take a
super position
uh code words in the dual space
as well as like a super position of like
some error ball and basically
um the ability to in his setting the the
cvp oracle lets you is the thing that
lets you convolve these two right and
your exciting
the unique to coding is a thing that
lets you do the convolution
exactly yes
um
good so so by a happy coincidence
uh so so random linear codes we uh the
the dover venom in your code is another
random linear code so we're sort of we
would be happy sort of information
theoretically
but we don't believe that you can
efficiently do the decoding
but fortunately the dual of a folded
reed solomon code the other thing that
we know is list recoverable actually
happens to be more or less another
folded retail woman code
which has essentially optimal list
decoding properties
and so that's going to be our
our code there's going to be a folded
read solomon code of of an appropriate
rate um in order basically we need we
need the rate to be you know a little
less than a half in the
the rate of the dual code to be a little
less than a half in order for us to be
able to do the list decoding
um
and that's it that's the
um
that's the specification of our problem
so so mark can you say what you need
from the code again we do you need that
if i pick a random
code word in the dual and uh
add half plus epsilon noise i should be
able to decode it to a unique uh
uh with high probability yes um
and that the the fact that
the fact that yeah yeah so so you know
list decoding is just potentially one
way of doing the decoding really what we
need is exactly what you said that
taking a random code word and random
errors um
you can decode uniquely with high
probability
um
there's actually some subtlety that i'll
actually discuss on the next slide to
that
um
and what we do is we show that it
basically follows from list decoding and
um
and then sort of more generally the rate
of the code more or less implies that
with random errors
um the solution to list decoding will be
a unique code word
do you really need it to be like really
unique or do you only need it to be like
only one element in the list which is
like permitted by your by your rule
uh no because because you actually need
to do the uncomputation right um
so if we go back
if we go if we go back here
you know we have actually oh because
you're in this because you're in the
development yeah yeah and we need to
actually actually like computing phases
yeah okay
um okay i i i do want to mention um that
there is a there is a caveat to all of
this or you know i i um you know things
may seem easier than they actually are
um and that's in general this with high
probability
a bit
is actually not necessarily good enough
um and it has to do with this
normalization that i've been sloppy
about so far so if you were to actually
write down the convolution theorem um
you do pick up a renormalization
constant um that's square root of n
where n is the n is basically the size
of the overall domain which is huge it's
it's exponential
um
and and what happens is when you try to
actually analyze things
um if you do it sort of the
the most natural way
um your error terms that the probability
that you're decoding failed um ends up
getting multiplied by the square root of
n term and suddenly non-negligible
becomes uh
you know noticeable and and potential
you know potentially destroys the the
algorithm
um
and and and in regular this was actually
also an issue except that the the
gaussians have such low
weight in the tails
that uh even after you know multiplying
by the square root of n you're actually
still happy
um in our case our error probability is
actually pretty it's it's negligible but
it's still pretty high and it's actually
uh higher than
than you know one over n and so if we
were going to do things the naive way we
end up we end up actually blowing things
up and and not getting you know not
being able to justify the correctness of
our algorithm and so we needed to
actually um
[Music]
look a little more carefully at you know
the exact error distribution you get and
sort of analyze things um
uh you know in a bit more delicate
manner in order to justify that the the
errors actually do not um blow up in our
case
so sort of do you use the fact that sort
of the errors cancel
you know you you're using something
about
the decoding algorithm the the error
distribution of the decoding algorithm
is that right or
yeah it's um
i i guess it's less about the the
um
i mean our you know our errors are we
can't really think of our errors as
uniform errors but yeah it's a
particular structure of our problem um
that allows us to
sort of
show that even though the error rate is
is not too low
that the errors are
are sort of distributed in a way that um
makes things okay and it it's sort of a
low-level thing
that
i
i probably can't convey over
over the slides um but it's just you
know i just want to you know point out
that uh this this state multiplying
um technique you know does potentially
run into difficulties um and and we ran
into this difficulty
in our work but we were able to overcome
it for our particular case
um
so i i had prepared a number of slides
kind of going into some more details on
the applications
um i i don't know
you know now that we're we're somewhat
over
um i don't know if we should if we
should just skip those um they're pretty
they're pretty high level um this this
you know what we saw so far was kind of
the the main
um
the main idea of the
paper
maybe um
you know i'm sure those would be would
be relevant in the
once we get to the either now or when
once we get to the panel one one way to
do it is um
is to
go to the panel and then
and you can talk about
in the course of that you can talk about
the applications
how long would it take you to actually
present those slides now
uh it might
10 to 15 minutes
probably
um
uh
maybe
you know
uh
we we should have a bit of a discussion
so shall we shall we start with the
discussion and then then jump back to
those two slices sure sure sounds good
um
so do you have anything by the way uh if
you have to prioritize one it seems like
there was some confusion about how the
results
don't contradict a so maybe if you had
slides repaired on the
proof of randomness that might be the
most
like illuminating ones to highlight if
you get to it
um
yeah i mean i could briefly talk about
the the proof of randomness it's
actually really
uh
uh
i mean the proof of
yeah the certifiable randomness um
is pretty easy
um
at least in the uniform setting um so
literally what the proof of randomness
is is just alice solves our problem um
so here here i wrote it in sort of like
what the actual queries of the oracle
would be um so she sends over a code
word
um such that if
the random oracle hashes of all the code
words all the symbols are zero and here
i'm you know i'm prepending with the
index and this is to just ensure that
all the
all the different coordinates are
independent
um so she just solves an instance of our
problem and and sends it to the receiver
and all the receiver does to generate
their random string is extract
from the random string
using a using a classical randomness
extractor
not extract from the random string
extract from the solution to the problem
um to get a random string
and yeah i didn't really go into
explaining why uh
in too too much detail why the a
conjecture implies this
um but
for intuition
um
suppose that um our alice was actually
able to deterministically come up with
a uh a solution c
um so what the a conjecture says
is that if you look well sorry so if
else were able to deterministically come
up with the code word um satisfying our
constraints
um in particular the first bit
of
that uh
that solution is also deterministic
and the a conjecture then says that well
we had a quantum algorithm that
deterministically produced some bit
then there's a classical algorithm
that's not too much slower that also
produces approximately that bit
and you just repeat this for every
single bit of the output
and you actually get a
classical algorithm
that will output the same answer as as
alice
um
and so that's roughly the idea is that
so for example if if the code word were
actually computed deterministically then
then it was then it would be classically
easy
according to the a conjecture
um
and
we extend this idea to uh higher min
entropy bounds to to show that
um
basically the code the solution c has to
have significant entropy
otherwise there's a classical algorithm
otherwise under the a conjecture there's
a classical algorithm that violates our
proof of hardness
um and once you have c having min
entropy you're done you just apply
randomness extraction to get to random
seed a random string
so sorry so does this idea say something
about the impossibility of sort of
search to
a decision to search the decision
reductions is sort of what you seem to
be saying right uh
or
uh i mean it says if you have uh
if you have a search problem that's
classically hard
if it's quantumly easy the only way it
can be quantumly easy is if um
the quantum algorithm is sort of
sampling from from a distribution within
entropy
i see
okay thanks
um
great um
okay wow uh thanks very much that was
really uh
very lovely talk yeah beautiful ideas
um
so um
at this point maybe shall we move on to
the to the panel
so
if
you stop sharing your